in washington earlier today president
biden held his first meeting with
canada's prime minister since taking
office
it was virtual instead of in person
because of
covet 19 and there's already a sticky
issue between the allies and neighbors
oil pipelines and energy policy white
house correspondent peter ducey has the
specifics tonight
north long good evening peter so there
are still 565 miles
between them president biden is hosting
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
for his first
bilateral meeting since coming to the
white house right
now and it comes about a month after
their first diplomatic
dustup about the cancellation of the
keystone xl pipeline permit
the prime minister raised his concerns
directly with the president has
previously and
he's of course welcome to today the
biden administration is less keen to
stop construction on another pipeline
the nord stream 2
a putin priority that runs from russia
to germany because
according to the wall street journal
when the state department sent congress
a list of companies they'll sanction if
involved with that project
it didn't have any names added to it
since the last report
in the trump era you guys are taking
credit for stuff that the previous
administration
did i i am not i am speaking for the
department of state
okay the people who have been working
this the people who are working this now
were the same people a month ago were
the same people
three months ago three months ago but
republicans here are most urgently
concerned
about 11 000 jobs lost here on the
keystone xl project
they are in some ways heartless if you
look at the cancellation of the keystone
pipeline
and the jobs lost because of that
cancellation the administration
won't budge citing the threat of a
changing climate the climate envoy john
kerry said that there are only nine
years left to save the world
from the effects of climate change does
president biden
share that assessment nine years i don't
have a new timeline to
to give you from here i can confirm for
you though that the president agrees
with
former secretary kerry that it's a
crisis uh that time is of the essence
we need to act quickly it's not clear
how quickly jobs killed by
climate-minded executive orders can be
replaced but the administration insists
fossil fuel workers can learn to do
something else
what president biden wants to do is make
sure those
folks have better choices that they have
alternatives
they can be the people who go to work to
make the solar panels
this approach is somewhat surprising
because the uncertainty created by
forcing fossil fuel workers to change
jobs without telling them when
or where that happens is similar to
something from biden's own youth when
his dad lost a fossil fuel job my dad
had a job in scranton and when cole died
and everything started to close up and
had to move across state lines to
delaware it was only 159 miles but it
seemed like the end of the world
the president's dad had to learn a new
trade he ended up
then getting a good job a decent job
managing a car dealership and the
president remembers
none of that was easy i thought about
how hard it must have been for my dad
so most of the things that biden is
trying to do differently than trump are
because
of the environment and this afternoon
justin trudeau
was talking about this joint communique
that canada and the us are going to put
out about their meetings
virtually today and he said he thinks
it's nice that
the us is not trying to take references
to climate change
out of a statement like that the way
that he says they did in the past but
instead
are trying to put them in brett
peter ducey live on the north lawn peter
thank you